Je m'appelle Tomas, j'ai 27ans
Je suis Bana, j'ai 22 ans
Je suis Mia, j'ai 20 ans
Environ 15 ans, je dirais
Toutes !
Toutes ? Et tu as quel âge ?
23 ! Donc 20 sur 23 ans
Norvège, Suède
Autriche, Suisse
Allemagne, Tanzanie
Costa Rica, Amérique, Canada
Quatre ou cinq
12 pays !
Quelque chose comme 15 pays
Un, deux, trois, Quatre ? Quatre !
Je suis citoyenne américaine
Je viens d'Arrabi
Donc tu es palestinienne ?
Oui ! J'ai habité un an aux Etats-Unis.
Je suis mexicain. J'ai habité au Mexique, Canada, Allemagne, Italie et maintenant je suis en Israël.
J'ai la citoyenneté allemande, je viens d'Allemagne.
Né en Israël, Grandi en Israël.
Tu viens de quel pays ?
Wow ! C'est dur pour nous...
Je suis palestinienne. Je suis arabe et je vis en Israël.
J'ai la citoyenneté Israëlienne donc je ne sais pas vraiment qui je suis.
Pas de soucis ! On peut dire que tu es palestinienne.
J'ai fait Israël de la même taille que l'Inde
C'est peut-être parce que j'ai cet amour pour Israël. Non ?
Est-ce que tu te rends compte à quel point tu as fait les USA énorme ?
Je les ai fait trop grands ?
Oui ! Vraiment beaucoup trop grand !
Tu vois ! Je savais que ça allait arriver. C'est pour ça que j'étais si anxieuse !
Je suis désolé ! C'est vrai ce que le monde vous a dit sur les américains !
C'est l'Inde ici ?
Oui !
Tu es allé en Inde récemment ?
Oui ! Il y'a 6 mois seulement.
Tu es allé combien de fois en Europe ?
Au moins 10 ou 12 fois.
Wow Oui ! Combien de fois es-tu allé en Afrique ?
En Afrique ? Je n'y suis jamais allé.
Tu sais quoi ? Je crois qu'on peut le voir sur ta carte !
- Oh m***de ! C'est l'Indonésie ?
- Oui...
- Où est l'Inde ?
- Ici !
Je crois que les îles sont vraiment sous-cotées.
Tout le monde oublie les îles !
J'imagine que les insulaires doivent se sentir oubliés mais on ne les oublie pas
Tu peux y passer plus de temps si tu veux.
Oui mais honnêtement, je n'ai pas plus de connaissances.
Et le Japon ?
Je trouve que la carte du monde et le globe, c'est vraiment beaux
Tu peux regarder ça pendant des jours !
Mais je le fais pas
Le Sri Lanka, je crois que c'est la première fois que je le vois sur une carte !
Oui... mais aussi, j'y suis allé !
Je pense que c'est bien d'avoir une éducation en architecture.
Tu sais dessiner et tu as un sens des proportions.
Oui!
Ça aide !
Les explorateurs du 16e siècle, 17e, 18e : c'est amusant de voir qu'ils imaginent le monde comme ça !
Ils croient vraiment que le monde est comme ça !
Parce qu'ils ne l'avaient pas cartographié.
Ou parfois, ils n'ont cartographié que le pays intéressants pour la route de la soie.
C'est amusant de voir que tout le long de l'histoire,
Les humains ont toujours interprété la taille du monde en fonction de
du lien culturel ou économique
Donc en fait, on continue de faire la même chose, on fait toujours des cartes du monde !
Mais on dirait que maintenant on a vraiment couvert tout le globe.
En tout cas, c'est ce que nous dit Google Maps
Sauf si on fait un globe, on déforme les proportions
Donc le Nord et le Sud sont complètement déformés sur la carte parce qu'ils sont loins de l'équateur
C'est amusant que même si on essaye de faire la vraie carte, en fait, on fait une. mauvaise carte dans tous les cas !
Et on le sait mais c'est amusant dans tous les cas